this weed is mad tight yeah man I'm so
fired up hey y'all let me ask you a
question on the real yeah yeah yeah go
here beer and man where my Dookie go
Oh
what my Dookie
where'd it go it go down in the toilet
you know that nah man I ain't stupid
where do we go after that probably
equipped later I don't know if it goes
down the sewer you know everybody go
down there yeah everybody's Dookie goes
down in the sewer
where my Dookie go after that they
washes out to the ocean I guess
hold up hold up dolphins swim with my
Dookie I don't know man I mean I don't
really don't know we're in the ocean yep
what happens to the Dookie I'm just
taking a stab like a wild guess all
right that the Dookie like probably go
up in the air and like evaporates and
then turns into the cloud or something a
Dookie cloud oh this
everybody's to keep mix up goes up in
the cloud and in the rains down that's
gangster I just can we stop talking
about Dookie right now I just thought uh
son yes what is it what is it Levi the
pieces of my Dookie yep falls on the
ground that's true
yep it becomes a plan okay okay that's
good now we're done with the Dookie talk
right do keep playing know that reaches
towards the sky
they say yeah Levi if my Dookie can make
it out of the hood maybe we can too
maybe maybe Levi
you